hello nostalgic guy remember it so you
don't have to Jurassic fucking Park when
this film came out people went nuts not
only did it have groundbreaking CGI
effects but it had action-packed
suspense a sense of awe and Wonder and
just seemed antic so when it was
re-released in 3d recently you bet your
ass I got over to the theater to relive
all those awesome memories and how did
it hold up it was awesome but maybe not
as awesome as I remember look I'm not
saying it's a bad movie far from it if
anything it's held up extraordinarily
well I'm just saying that while we were
so blown away by how huge it was we
might have overlooked some problems that
we either didn't see or chose to ignore
I know something like Jurassic Park 3 is
worse and trust me we'll get to that
train wreck on our time but it's still
an interesting journey looking back at
something that was so groundbreaking and
popular without the nostalgia goggles so
let's take a look at adventure 65
million years in the making or three
this is Jurassic Park so we start out in
Spielberg's favorite place to go in all
of his movies spotlight fetish land yeah
I don't know if you've noticed but this
guy is obsessed with shining spotlights
in your face as much as humanly possible
every frame feels like a whimsical
police interrogation
they try to transport one of the highly
intelligent Raptors via portal cube when
of course something goes wrong you know
was there really no other way to get
these things into their cages
brute force doesn't do much compared to
common sense I mean look at the forklift
they can lift it just a little bit
higher and dropping it or tranquilizers
why not tranquilizers gonna just knock
these things out and I slipped them in
that way or the Raptors too smart for
that plan
run away in comedic fishing so they lose
one of the workers in the attack as we
cut to the prettiest mullet obsessed
paleontologists to roam the earth
they're led by dr. grant played by I
swear I'm not a New Zealanders in deal
look at the Halfmoon shape want to have
one of those o'clock of birds evading a
predator and dr. Sadler his girl via
fuck buddy play by Laura Dern who seems
to always suffer from terminal mumbling
ice-cream scoop up peanut butter before
coming to the set well maybe dinosaurs
have more in common with present-day
birds and they do with reptiles look at
the vertebrae full of air sacs and
hollows just like a bird and even the
word Raptor means bird of prey Raptors
were very aware of this when they were
naming themselves that doesn't look very
scary more like a 6-foot turkey turkey
so he scares the little kid by showing
him something he never thought he'd see
on a hunt for dinosaur bones dinosaur
bone ah I have one of those I don't want
that kid breed of child dr. gray
but that work is interrupted by John
Hammond Bloom the bugpipes
who offers to fund their dig further if
they offer outside opinion on his new
due to the loss of the work earlier I
mean let's face it in your particular
field you'll have the top minds yes you
have no idea how computers work and you
study ancient plant like clearly nobody
would be more qualified I like you I can
tell instantly about people it's a gift
obviously he took them to consideration
when he hired this guy Denis nedra you
played by Wayne Knight before his heart
decided he wanted to live who he seems
betraying John Hammond by handing over
the dinosaur embryos to evil dinosaur
makers I guess in order to get more
money and you might notice one of the
main problems with the first third of
this movie
it focuses a great deal amount of time
somehow hastily rushing a ton of
exposition one delivery 50,000 more for
each viable embryo we are facing a
twenty million dollar lawsuit as a
particular pebble in Marcia represents
my investment seven o'clock tomorrow
night on the east dock outside opinion
but it's alright to account for that if
they make the characters motivations and
story arts disgustingly simple even down
to dressing them in care-bear colors so
you can easily remember which one is
which which ones grant oh he's the one
in blue which one's Hammond oh he's the
one in white which ones he hey ho
everyone will fall in love with until
they realize he's just gonna do that one
doe for the rest of his life until they
want to dig their brains out with a fork
because he's so goddamn irritating
that's the darkly dressed evil one known
as Jeff Goldblum
yeah
Goldblum or The Wizard of Oz as I like
to call him what's in a complete unknown
before this flick but he became a
household name after it became a hit and
people fell in love with his performance
and at the time it was kind of charming
people never heard this kind of
performance in the blockbuster film
before we're gonna conduct an experiment
it should be still the cars bouncing up
and down but that's our case but once we
discovered that he fell in love with his
performance even more than we fell in
love with his performance to a point
where he never wanted to leave that
performance but we do end up asking
ourselves how the fuck do we ever like
this performance to begin with there is
good luck in this new song out of your
head if will be in your brain for weeks
till you're dead for 50 miles the Korea
defense are in place and the concrete
notes and the motion sensor tracking
systems novels dear bye relax
the only thing we don't have is security
in case a storm comes or the power goes
out but we have this die for that so we
good we good spent no expense
I shut you down John in 48 hours I'll be
accepting your apology
so they arrived at the star attraction
laura dern mug for the trailer and we
get our first look at Gertie its mr.
dinosaur welcome to Jurassic Park
they're moving in herds they do move in
herds really that's the big teardrop our
line kind of random isn't it I mean is
that kind of like looking out over the
herd and saying they eat their own shit
they do eat their own shit
haiman takes them to the visitors center
to show them how they're made apparently
it was done through the miracle cloning
one of the many illegal processes I'm
sure went into making this place a
reality DNA strand like me is a
blueprint for building a living thing
and sometimes Oh spotlight fetish I
don't care if I'm the only director in
the world who hasn't I will make you a
star there are mosquitoes just like
today after biting a Dinah South the
mosquito would land on the branch of a
tree and get stuck in the SAP the tree
sap would get hard and become fossilized
just like a dinosaur bone preserving the
mosquito inside okay even if you were to
buy this half-baked science that even
Donatello would call a little suspicious
what are the chances of finding tons of
mosquitoes not only millions of years
old not only have bitten every popular
dinosaur to be marketed but also all
happened to get stock in tree sap did
they all happen to be in the same nest
during the greats Apple ants of
gajillion BCE Wow it's a cold day but I
think we've been every popular most
marketable dinosaur known to man that's
what I love binge drinking with you guys
now let's rest our little tummies before
we cook up whatever's left of them
no I can't I wonder if I'm the blood
donor we gets a whimsical moment number
I'm not even gonna bother counting as we
see one of the baby dinosaurs being born
the species is is it's a velociraptor he
bred Raptors ah so he can't identify the
dinosaur from his trademark mate kid wet
pants peach even when he's holding the
damn thing right in his motherfucking
hands great job picking those top minds
you were talking about there Hammond
spent no expense this brings us to the
projector room where I'm sure Spielberg
is projecting right now with how much a
spotlight fetish is being fueled oh so
backlit oh so illuminating oh oh I could
hump the white out why that makes on the
side of their heads before we can charge
anything we want 2,000 a day 10,000 a
day and people will pay it this park was
not built to cater only for the
super-rich everyone in the world has the
right to enjoy these animals yeah
everyone should be allowed to fly two
personal helicopters to their Hawaiian
Islands after getting storm insurance
we're looking after the little guy but
golden ah ah is not happy you're stood
on the shoulders of geniuses to
accomplish something as fast as you
could and before you even knew your hand
you you've patented it and packaged it
and slapped it on a plastic lunchbox and
now selling it you wanna sell it well
wow that was an excellent argument
against the lost world I mean everything
you said in there I totally agree
you four are gonna have a spot of
company out in the park okay good the
appetizers arrived now we can start our
tour with the latest and greatest in
high-tech ingenuity cd-rom holy shit
it's packing cd-rom oh my god Tommy it
doesn't have next week tell me it
doesn't have act
the appropriate information will be
automatically selected welcome to
Jurassic Park
whether they got in there King Khan oh
come on eco worked in three more others
into that sentence what are they all got
off in there
King Kong but sadly the tour doesn't
seem to be going very well as none of
the dinosaurs show up to be seen
but it's okay because Goldblum uses his
traditional pick-up tricks that always
seem to get him women at TGI Fridays
tiny variations
the orientation of the hairs on your
they want a blood to standing or vessels
imperfections escape yeah it's like a
new NBC sitcom rambles and mumbles one's
a horny Kia Titian the others a giggling
plant expert who doesn't want to get
married but surprisingly wants kids for
some reason together they make the
greatest couple nobody can understand or
want to listen to since Jackie Chan and
Chris Tucker rambles and mumbles coming
soon to NBC wow that was fast
they get out the car and stumble across
a sick Triceratops butts antler is
determined to figure out what's causing
the sickness now in reality this scene
serves no purpose to the plot apart from
separating satler from the group and
let's be honest it only exists so kids
can giggle what he says this line that
is one big pile of shit your career in a
nutshell the knee tree has to hurry with
those embryos or else the obvious video
that everyone the audience said was an
obvious video seriously you can crop
that shot just a notch says the storm is
coming and that the ship has to leave
with everyone on it a home of work how
one's blurry it is oh yeah
so he says the power is gonna go in and
out thinking he can make it back in time
before anybody notices but he gets lost
resulting in all the power shutting down
and the cars getting stuck in the worst
place possible
and this leads to easily the best
character in the whole movie the
absolute star of the whole goddamn thing
fuck
this badass mother owns it this scene is
about as perfectly paced and perfectly
suspenseful as a scene can get
I think everything about her can be
summed up in that one awesome war yeah I
think you translated that roar every
single one would declare her ability of
just owning this goddamn movie
but things get real when bulgy eyes and
young ferrisbueller
are being attacked comedy for me
yeah what was the line that Hammond said
earlier in 48 hours I'll be accepting
your apology
I'm sorry lawyer
tastes like deep-rooted insecurities and
bitterness grant gives a bulgy eyes out
but young Ferris Bueller is still stuck
in the car and the t-rex the frozen
I'm sorry I need a minute to recover
from some awesomeness
play the music
you
we do each other good to your ex we do
each other Ryu
back to the story neither gets its card
stuck and does his best to pull it out
was that a cartoon sound effect the
Schumacher take off her from one second
of filming buddy comes across a nasty
visitor or at least she becomes nasty
when the prop guy pulls the strings yep
just ruin that scene forever Priya grant
manages to get young Ferris Bueller out
of the tree and tries making their
weight back meanwhile Sadler comes
across Goldblum just in time to partake
in another badass t-rex scene
it bounces
don't forget the mirror scene that
fortunately makes no sense but still so
goddamn cool yeah that so doesn't add up
Hey look on the bright side at least you
give Toy Story to something the parody
the next morning granted the kids come
across some friendly breccia sources I
have to admit this is one of the lesser
effects in the movie I don't know maybe
because it's at a profile but does
anyone else think it looks like just a
giant expensive sock puppet I just think
it is well I know we sounded weird to me
too now that you can make the phrase I
like how sad all that natural but it
goes pretty Lucas there doesn't it but I
don't like sand
I like snot suddenly grant discovers the
dinosaurs are breeding which seems
impossible seeing how all of them are
females mutated the dinosaur genetic
code and blended it with that of frogs
now some West African frogs been known
to spontaneously change sex from male to
female in a single sex environment funny
how this is common knowledge to me and
yet none of the highly paid scientists
who put this together ever consider this
a possibility spent no expense but at
least they did think of this possibility
a lysine contingency lines new
contingency is intended to prevent the
spread of the animals in case they ever
get off the island
dr. woolens through the gene that
creates a single faulty enzyme and
protein metabolism the animals can't
manufacture the amino acid lysine unless
they're completely supplied with lysine
by us they swim into a coma and die oh
great why don't you do that absolutely
out of the question
okay guess we can just add this to the
grocery list of scenes that go nowhere
in this movie yeah really think about it
there's quite a few weren't there a man
died showing up because his daughter's
gear divorce
Goldblum hitting out Sadler and her fuck
buddy fighting out digging through Dino
shit the lysine those weird fucking
goggles spent no expense you spare
purpose though lots and lots of purpose
but I've had it with these motherfucking
dinosaurs on this motherfucking aisle it
agrees to shut down the system and
restart it oh why don't I just shoot all
my movies at our White House
I can read that in somehow it's all it
worked what do you mean it worked
everything's still off well maybe this
shutdown took the circuit breakers all
we have to do is turn them back on we're
on the breakers maintenance here the
other end of the compound three minutes
I can have power back on the entire park
well now just to be safe I want
everybody in the emergency bunker wait I
just hear that right you're sending the
only computer guy on the island outside
with the killer dinosaurs alone huh can
see anything going wrong there you go
just going down the road oh you mean
like the way you just let that guy
stroll down the road oh yeah the blank
dude can handle his own but when the
pretty white lady has to go I don't know
suit up it's too dangerous out there
even Hammond can't bear to see her go
where they easily toss the black guy I
told you give me a really good look we
can discuss sexism and survival
situations when I get back
it is funny him confusing strength and
gender see how most of the things on the
island trying to kill have a vagina
so Sadler makes it to the building and
turns on the power just as young Ferris
Bueller is climbing the fence
oh yes they go huh Sadler on the other
hand she gets out okay but velociraptor
dundee seems to have his own problems to
deal with
waiting for me to turn around to
acknowledge your intelligence clever
gloating egotistical girl yep if you
ever notice these things are damn smart
even when gray leaves the kids alone in
a building with no lock doors how stupid
they managed to open up the doors Corner
them in the kitchen and yet somehow
never managed to get these dwarves yeah
you go on and on about how smart they
are and how they can even track diehard
hunters get little kids with literally
no way I'll give them the slip
I mean quickly just be like Oh Stephanie
could you be awesome and stand guard at
the door while I sniff our dinner out of
course Vanessa thank you no prob
hey did you hear about Andre a
spontaneous change of sex yeah that was
weird so I guess it the kids get away
and meet up with grant and cemre well
get them to the control room to turn
everything back on including the door
locks which was kind of stupid hooking
up everyday door locks to their computer
Jenna thought that one through spent no
expense
so while bulgy eyes tries to boot up all
the power to the park because they
clearly went into great detail about
what a computer expert she is see it's
up to young Ferris Bueller to hand
settlor the gun hand Sattler the gun the
chair doesn't need a massage
as much as Sadler needs the gun they got
the power bag on and at least they have
more ammo they can use for later
or missile lobbing four times are the
rector's agents from the matrix how the
hell can you miss four times hitting a
dinosaur they climb aboard that thing
the Flintstones eat at the end credits
when it seems like they're cornered how
the hell could they get out of this one
you are the most awesome god damn thing
even though it makes no sense how they
come in here you come in even though
your footsteps always make the ground
shake you just gave the most Catholics
awesome ending this movie deserve
all she needs is a mic drop I swear
that's the only thing missing she
fucking owns everything that ever
existed she just needs a mic drop and
thus they all seem to make it out okay
mammoths next time
definitely mammoths oh my touching story
arc is complete let's split in the third
film okay and the moral of the story
kids when a white Scottish man offers
you to see his park who say no
and that's Jurassic Park it's got as
flaws even some major major flaws but
I'm sorry it still fucking awesome the
effects for the most part still look
great the story is not devoid of
intelligent conversation the characters
thought maybe a little too simplistic at
times are still likable and it still has
the size and scope to not only enchant
but also scare it suspenseful and fun
despite that there's some typical
Spielberg moments both good and bad not
to mention just the straight-up awesome
factor it knows what to give the
audience and just how much suspension of
disbelief we can lend to still enjoy it
as action-packed adventures go this is
one there's still a lot of fun and very
impressive and of course let's be honest
here it made the t-rex a motherfucking
star again
um